nous sommes en tête au premier tour
c'est l'un des deux candidats delà du ps
arrivé en tête au premier tour des
élections législatives
william martin a obtenu 32% des
suffrages dans la 11e circonscription
des yvelines il devance la candidate de
la majorité présidentielle
aurélie pia senza avec 25% des voix nous
sommes donc largement en tête nous
sommes même en tête dans quatre villes
sur sept dans l'ensemble de la de la
circonscription avec d'excellents scores
à trappes à la verrière et même à
elancourt autres territoires où la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale et devant la majorité
présidentielle la 8e circonscription
benjamin lucas a récolté 33 % des
exprimés contre 24% des suffrages pour
edwige hervieux candidate du mouvement
ensemble il ya aujourd'hui une volonté
de faire barrage emmanuel macron de ne
pas subir une politique injuste et
brutal la retraite à 65 ans la baisse
continue du pouvoir d'achat les prix qui
augmentent et les salaires qui stagnent
et puis de l'espoir parce que nous
portons un projet de justice sociale un
projet pour le pouvoir d'achat pour la
dignité pour le respect des citoyennes
et des citoyens avec l'union de ces
mouvements de la france un soumise au
parti socialiste en passant par le parti
communiste ou encore europe ecologie les
verts la gauche signe son retour dans
les yvelines sur les douze
circonscriptions aux candidats de la
nuque ps sont au second tour on annoncé
la gauche est à peine six mois comme
morte et en fait nous voilà au second
tour dans cinq circonscriptions y
compris la nôtre ici avec un score qui
est dans la moyenne nationale dans les
25 % on connaît à la sociologie de notre
circonscription sait que ça va être
difficile vu justement cette sociologie
là mais si tous les abstentionnistes et
bien vont voter pour nous on peut a
remporté cette circonscription en
relativisant par rapport à la
participation la gauche redevient une
force politique de premier plan sur le
territoire y benoît en 2017 aucun
candidat de gauche n'avait réussi à
accéder au second tour des élections
législatives